most people never realize their dreams
they never get the car they want start
the business they want make the money
they want because most people are so
busy being afraid that they never take
their shot at a real life most people
choose their path out of fear disguised
as practicality you do the smart thing
the safe thing you go to school that
you're supposed to you get a job like
you're supposed to you get married and
have kids like you're supposed to who
the heck is setting up all these rules
for your life who are these people
telling you what you can and cannot do
and more importantly why are you
listening to them have your parents
accomplish what you want to accomplish
has your guidance counselor done what
you want to do even though what they
tell you that you should do is that out
of love how can they advise you when
they've never gone where you want to go
why do you let their limited view of the
world hold you back from doing something
great I want you right now to pause and
take a look at your life look at your
friends look at your family look at the
books you read the videos you watch and
the media you consume you have hidden
talents that you're not using because
your environment is holding you where
you are you might watch a motivational
video attend a seminar
read an inspiring book and have a brief
moment of boldness a moment where you
believe in yourself a moment where you
believe that your dreams are possible a
moment where you believe that your
talents are valuable and the next day
you wake up and you're right back to
where you started because BAM your
environment smashes you back to where
you were you need to decide whether
you're going to live your life or
someone else's version of your life find
that hidden talent of yours and nurture
it believe in it pursue it relentlessly
stop listening to the doubters the
haters and the naysayers if someone
hasn't done what you want to do their
advice is meaningless
who are they to counsel you if anything
you should do the exact opposite of what
they say because you don't want a life
like theirs if you want a great life
then you need to do something that you
are great at that's always the start
trust your heart not your head and
follow your passion it will lead you to
places that your head cannot contemplate
you need to have an illogical irrational
irrevocable love for what you're doing
you need to embrace your hidden talent
and show the world what you can do then
change your environment to cultivate an
aura of greatness surround yourself with
people ideas and resources that push you
to stretch your comfort zone and become
the best version of yourself eject the
deadweight and negativity from your life
create a morning routine and ritual to
start your day off inspired and
motivated not just every now and then
but every single day inspired and
motivated you have an important mission
to accomplish and every day you waste is
one last day you have to make your
dreams happen now I don't know what your
hidden talent is but I know it's
powerful it's something you can change
the world with and you can either
believe that but believe what all the
underachievers around you think it's
time to start living your version of
your life no more excuses